la crisis económica Argentina sigue tras
registrar un 8,4% de aumento
inflacionario en abril y la Industria
del calzado ha sido la más perjudicada
con un crecimiento del 10,8%. esto
golpea a los consumidores pero también a
los pequeños productores es el caso de
Juan capano propietario de un taller de
zapatos en Lomas del Mirador localidad
cercana a la ciudad de Buenos Aires a mí
todos los proveedores me facturan en
pesos
[Música]
todos los días me cambian los precios
para Juan es el peor momento de la
industria Argentina desde la década del
90 pese al duro contexto se niega a
despedir alguno de sus 40 empleados Si
das un poquito vueltas por la fábrica te
das cuenta porque uno sigue adelante
detrás de cada uno de los operarios que
tenés acá trabajando Tenés una familia
atrás la situación agobia a los
eslabones más pequeños de la cadena que
deben Buscar formas de subsistir las
sensaciones que la gente quiere comprar
pero no llega y bueno para tratar de
incentivar la venta vos tenés que
ofrecerle alguna alternativa que en este
caso son las cuotas cuotas sin interés
que En definitiva digamos vos absorbes
el costo pero tenés un poquito más de
venta con una inflación interanual del
108,8%, una pobreza superior al 39% y
una alta tasa cambiaria sobrevivir es un
desafío para los argentinos que nos
tendrán elecciones presidenciales en
octubre buscando una solución a la